buongiorno a tutti sono gabriele
galimberti e sono un fotografo e quindi
iniziò subito la mia presentazione
facendo rivedere quella che è la mia
immagine preferita di sempre
no non è questo avete sbagliato qualcosa
questa questi sono fotografia è stata
scattata nel 1970 più o meno a rigutino
quindi a pochi chilometri da qua e
questi sono mio nonno quello in piedi i
miei genitori sono quelli che si baciano
io sono nato qualche anno dopo e sono
cresciuto a castiglion fiorentino per
circa 25 anni
i miei genitori sono mia mamma è
un'insegnante elementare il mio babbo
invece geometra quindi loro sono sempre
avuto il mito del posto fisso e anno
diciamo sempre desiderato per me e mia
sorella forse la stessa cosa come si
immaginavano che io da grande avrei
fatto un lavoro con abbastanza sicuro e
con un posto fisso in realtà ero già un
po di belle da giovane quindi quando mi
chiedevano cosa volevo fare da grande e
io rispondevo lo skater perché tony hawk
ce l'aveva fatta quindi sono messo a
fare anch'io
oppure il musicista anche qui aveva una
valanga di esempio da portare ai miei di
persone che stavano fatta e invece
questi di sogni più o meno quando hai
vent'anni sono un po se volete perché
dopo aver preso il diploma da geometra
per seguire le orme del babbo mi sono
trovato di ad una scrivania disegnare
villette a schiera per otto ore al
giorno e quindi dopo pochi mesi sentito
subito che quella non era una cosa che
voglio fare e allora ho pescato un po in
un'altra delle mie passioni che oltre lo
skate è una musica avevo quella della
fotografia di un giorno sono tornato a
casa e mi ha detto io voglio lasciare il
lavoro che voglio fare il fotografo loro
mi hanno subito appoggiato perché forse
immaginavano che da lì a breve avrei
aperto il negozio in paese avrei fatto
il fotografo di matrimoni di comunioni
quindi di nuovo una cosa abbastanza
sicura e fissa io realtà per comunque mi
hanno appoggiato e allora mi hanno
aiutato ad iscrivermi una scuola di
fotografia firenze che è durata tre anni
e quella è stata l'unica volta in vita
mia che ero un bravo studente mi faceva
veramente quello stavo studiando quindi
ho avuto dei buoni risultati a scuola e
subito dopo questo corso iniziato a
lavorare ma non nel negozietto di paese
ma o instaurare per fotografi
professionisti di milano e di firenze
quindi in quegli anni ho imparato
fotografare prima i gioielli poi
l'arredamento e poi le modelle perché mi
sono buttato un po sulla moda e quindi
visto che avevo poco più di vent'anni
lavorare con le modelle mi faceva
abbastanza da sempre circondato da belle
donne per per un po di anni ho resistito
in quel settore da poi è successo
qualcosa alcuni anni dopo che ha
cambiato tutto perché non so se lo
sapete ma cassino fiorentino dove vivo
lo aveva vissuto quasi per tutta la vita
c'è una università americana e quindi
ogni due mesi arrivano centinaia di
studenti che popolano il paese in una di
queste ondate di studenti americani ho
conosciuto una ragazza texana ci siamo
innamorati e quindi grazie a lei per la
prima volta in vita mia
qualche mese dopo però su un aereo da
solo che andava in texas e in quel
momento insomma questo primo volo è
ancora non ricordo il primo volo da solo
lontano è stato subito nata una nuova
passione dentro di me in quella del
viaggio sentito che stavo bene quindi
nei mesi successivi
nell'arco di sei mesi diciamo sono di
texas 4 volte quindi ero pendolare
avanti e indietro da dall'italia al
texas e quindi li ho subito capito che
dovevo fare qualcosa per combinare il
mio lavoro a questa nuova passione per
il viaggio perché non volevo più farne a
meno
non volevo più smette di viaggiare e
allora la soluzione era abbandonare il
mondo della moda e dedicarmi con la
fotografia qualcosa diverso quindi ho
iniziato in quel momento ad avvicinarmi
forse è un po al mondo del giornalismo
al mondo del documentario e ha iniziato
a produrre a produrre delle prime le
prime storie da solo quindi ho fatto i
primi viaggi auto producendoli quindi
pagando di tasca mia e sono andato prima
in india poi in brasile ho passato un po
di mesi in questi posti producendo delle
storie che poi tornando in italia
cercava di vendere giornali alcune volte
va bene altre volte no però in quei due
tre anni diciamo che hanno iniziato a
crearmi una piccola rete di contatti e
quindi un po il lavoro tanta nino
iniziato ad arrivarmi fino a che un
giorno un editore svizzero mi ha
proposto il lavoro da fare in cina
quindi per un libro quindi mi chiedevano
di fare delle fotografie per un libro
che sarebbe uscito in contemporanea le
olimpiadi cinesi e
il lavoro era super interessante però il
budget era bassissimo
io comunque volevo farlo e allora
inventare qualcosa per andare in cina a
basso costo e rimanere da due mesi a
lavorare un amico mi aveva parlato del
couchsurfing come una nuova forma di
viaggio che a basso costo e quindi io mi
sono un po informato fatto di ricerca
cerca di capire cosa fosse questo
couchsurfing e ho scoperto cos'era è un
social network quello che io chiamo il
social network dell'ospitalità che ha
sostanzialmente come facebook
ognuno di noi può iscriversi avere la
propria pagina questa per esempio è la
mia e dove tutti scrivi fai il tuo
profilo
mettete foto e le tue informazioni e ti
connetti a tutti gli altri couchsurfer
che sono iscritti a questa questo sito
che sono attualmente nove milioni in
tutto il mondo ci sono ovunque e sparsi
gli unici due posti noi non li potete
trovare sono la corea del nord e cuba
perché lì è vietato fare capo e sterpi e
quindi io mi sono iscritta questa cosa e
ho deciso di viaggiare in cina usando
questo questo metodo che sostanzialmente
funziona una volta ti iscrivi tu puoi
andare nella pagina
io in quel momento sono andato nella
pagina di couchsurfing cinesi cioè di
pechino
ho guardato chi erano ha chiesto
ospitalità e mi hanno risposto in 17
quindi io nell'arco di due mesi sono
stato ospite di 17 famiglie diversa
pechino questa per esempio la pagina dei
couchsurfer di arezzo e sono 1517 quindi
ce ne sono tanti iscritti anche qua e
qui è che tutto funziona sul sul sulle
referenze quindi c'è una sorta di
sicurezza una volta che tu sei ospiti
qualcuno ospiti qualcuno devi poi
lasciare nella sua pagina un giudizio
una referenza quindi è un sistema
abbastanza sicuro perché se qualcuno si
comporta male fa una cosa è sbagliato
quando è ospite ospitato ospitante viene
viene lasciato una licenza negativa e
automaticamente quella persona non verrà
più in è ospitata e ne invitata quindi
niente che sono partito per la cina è
quello che è successo lei è stato che la
prima volta il fatto che selfin il primo
la prima volta che ha dormito a casa di
qualcuno
ero a casa di uno studente ventenne che
condivideva l'appartamento con altri
circa venti studenti e tutti dormivano
per terra
mi sono messo per terra in questo in
questa stanzone oggi questi studenti
tutti noi condividevamo un bagno una
cucina in condizioni igieniche
discutibili tre giorni dopo
per fortuna è tutto cambiato sono
arrivato a casa della signora
ricchissima in un piano alto di un
grattacielo nel centro di scienze e
avevo la mia camera con il mio letto
matrimoniale
il mio bagno privato con una vasca
idromassaggio questa casa ricchissima
però c'è una cosa buffa c'era tutte
tutta questa casa era certo non c'erano
le sorprese intero primo kinder ovunque
nelle mensole nei mobili e quindi ho
chiesto la signora ma com'è che
colleziona in queste queste cose le
fanno neanche le collezioni sono la
proprietaria della fabbrica che le
produce e quindi li né lui dà subito
l'idea che il couchsurfing era in realtà
un social network incredibilmente
interessante perché due persone così
estreme estremamente diversa i due
estremi della società cinese in realtà
avevano qualcosa in comune entrambi
iscritti al couchsurfing in entrambi
avevano voglia di ospitarli e quindi li
ho avuto questa idea di fare un progetto
su questo social network
volevo girare il mondo facendo
couchsurfing quindi girare il mondo e
mai dormire in hotel ma sempre essere
ospite qualcuno
tornato in italia ho proposto l'idea da
alcuni giornali con cui ha lavorato e ho
avuto fortuna che repubblica
nello specifico il settimanale d di
repubblica ha deciso di sponsorizzare mi
e mi ha fatto partire per un giro del
mondo durata due anni questa è la mappa
di quello che ho fatto in cui in ogni
posto era ospite di una famiglia quindi
ho dormito a casa loro
tutto questo veniva poi io fotografavo
le famiglie che mi ospitavano e nel
giornale appariva così una pagina ogni
sabato dove veniva pubblicata la foto è
una storia che scrivevo per descrivere
chi erano i couchsurfer che vengono
ospitate una settimana questo per
esempio in australia
e questo in cina king e ogni volta
cercavo di fare a fare queste persone
non nel divano dove ho dormito ma in
situazioni in cui poi mi davano degli
spunti per scrivere anche della storia e
presente questa ragazza si chiama juve
che se in questa scritta che ha trovato
lungo il fiume via chungking significa
luna splendente mentre lei parlando un
giorno mi dice il mio nome significa
luna ma io mi sento come il sole che
purtroppo qua non splende mai perché
tanto di questo inquinamento e quindi la
storia che poi ho scritto era più legato
a questo c'è una descrizione della
questa persona ma anche questo questo
aneddoto di questo racconto che mi
faceva e quindi da lì sono partito e ha
fatto che a bruxelles fino a casa di
questi musicisti thailandesi che mi
hanno portato in giro per bangkok a
concerti tutta la settimana
oppure sono finito per natale a casa di
una famiglia messicana quindi quella in
primo piano ora che è la ragazza
iscritta al couchsurfing prossimo stato
ospite di tutta la famiglia per tutto il
periodo natale quindicenne e tacchino
tequila tutte le sere a cantare
ramazzotti spagnola tutte le sere oppure
in malesia stato ospite da questo
ragazzo che in casa quando quando mia mi
ha detto per ospitarne spero non ti dia
noi a dormire con gli animali che
pensava verso dei gatti
in realtà in camera con me sono nove
pittoni e due iguane qui era la mattina
dopo che stava accarezzando il pitone
l'iguana mentre guardava una televisione
sono stato fare surf in alaska con meno
25 gradi
con questo tipo abbastanza pazzo ma che
mi ha convinto a buttarmi in acqua
oppure questa era presentatrice del
telegiornale delle filippine
anche lei una abbastanza ricca è nota
nel suo paese ma iscritta al
couchsurfing aperto casa e ho dormito
nel suo divano per una settimana
questo è un il figlio nella famiglia
mormone a nello utah insomma tantissime
storie una donna
qui alle isole fiji lei incinta
all'ottavo mese e mezzo quindi avrebbe
potuto partorire da un momento all'altro
mentre ero lì è partita una foto è
questo trapassati una coppia inter abbia
questo in nel nord del canada
un allevatore di cani da slitta quindi
un'esperienza molto bella perché mi ha
portato in giro per la slitta con i cani
insomma molto molto emozionante e la
cosa divertente questa storia qua è che
siccome in questo posto ma c'erano circa
meno 47 quel giorno c'era una
temperatura gelida in questa casa non
c'è acqua corrente perché se piacerebbe
mi turbi quindi per fare la doccia
dovevo scendere due chilometri a valle
al distributore di benzina dove ci sono
le docce
per per il pubblico e il bagno non c'è
in casa ma il bagno quella stanzina
accanto verde che è assolutamente un
buco per terra che scende al 34 metri
dove quello che va di fare lo fai lì e
io mi lamentavo del freddo invece
praticamente fa guarda migliora
d'inverno perché l'estate ci sono gli
orsi
quindi meglio il freddo che york ci sono
anche couchsurfer che che hanno la
regola in casa sono cup surfer naturisti
nudisti e quindi la regola in casa erano
vestiti e mi sono adeguata la regola
ho dormito la questione di nuovo in cina
lo ha fotografato così perché lui mi
diceva che la cina l'unico paese che sta
correndo verso il futuro e quindi ho
deciso di fotografarlo correnti mentre
corre una coppia a malta conosciuti su
internet poi sposati a malta quindi le
antenne simboleggiano un po questa
l'opinione a questo su internet lui è
uno studente della bible university in
botswana e sta studiando per diventare
il prete carismatico insomma tante
storie
la paz in bolivia questo è un attore a
bollywood queste a panama ragazza si è
anche questa ricchissima aveva vari
porsche parcheggiati nel giardino un
dottore in zambia in albania
questo è uno dei cult set chiuso lati
del mondo in mezzo al sahara in algeria
però è una guida del deserto quindi a
una piccola chiavetta usb con cui si
connette ad internet sia iscritto al
kite surfer ai couchsurfing e io sono
stato suo ospite questo da eating e
questa l'ultima foto di questa selezione
del couchsurfing perché questa è stata
l'ultima tappa del mio viaggio e
casualmente proprio questa ragazza ci
siamo innamorati avuto una storia di due
anni quindi il couchsurfing holes oltre
ad avermi dato di lavoro è un progetto
ma a un certo punto mi ha dato anche un
po un po un amore e in quegli anni che
girava il mondo poi comunque tenevo
anche sempre antenne alzate per per
vedere altre storie che mi stavano
intorno quindi in quel periodo tutti i
miei amici stavano avendo figli allora
in qualche modo era sempre circondato da
bambini ogni volta che a verona gli
amici e ho iniziato interessarmi un po
al mondo dei bambini e ho deciso di fare
un progetto dedicato a loro quindi
girando il mondo ha fotografato bambini
ovunque andassi con i loro giochi
preferiti sono tutti i bambini tra i 3
ei 5 anni
e io ho chiesto loro fatto di vedere
quali sono i vostri giochi quindi li ho
fotografati questo esempio costa rica
questa le filippine in australia
questo ad haiti questa è una delle prime
foto che ho fatto in realtà questa
castiglion fiorentino il valdichiana ama
giocare con le mucche del nonno bellino
fotografarla con tutti gli attrezzi
della stalla questa zanzibar questo che
invece un bambino che sogna di fare il
motociclista a bangkok
questo in zambia di nuovo un posto c'è
una organizzazione che porta che ha un
laboratorio politico dai quindi un posto
dove i giochi non ci sono ma sono
tantissimi occhiali e quindi giorno con
gli occhiali in ucraina vuol fare il
poliziotto forse non si sa in cina
questo in messico questo di nuovo negli
stati uniti per fare il pilota perché il
babbo pilota questo in kenya e tutte
queste fotografie sono 54 in 54 paesi
diversi sono uscite come sotto forma di
libro sei mesi fa con un editore
americano conquistò tuttora lavorando a
un altro progetto e in tutti questi
viaggi i miei genitori che prima
iniziano sempre un po preoccupato in
latta che partivo perché appunto che lo
aspettavano un lavoro molto più
tranquilla invece già il mondo iniziano
sempre molto preoccupati ma ora hanno
imparato a stare tranquilli ogni volta
che una persona invece che non è mai
tranquilla quando parte mia nonna mia
nonna però non è preoccupata per i miei
viaggi perché spesso non sa neanche dove
sto andando sì dico che vanno in malawi
lai probabilmente pensa che sia dietro
siena non ha molta idea di dove il
malawi però lei sempre preoccupata del
cibo ma dove vai ma mangi bene ma hanno
preparato da mangiare style.it cucino io
perché perché te ne vai allora ho deciso
un giorno di fare un progetto anche qui
sempre globale dedicato a mia nonna è
quindi iniziato a fotografare donne in
tutto il mondo se mi son fatto ospitare
a casa di nonna e ho chiesto a loro
cucinatemi qualcosa perché se non mi
hanno preoccupato
e quindi ho fotografato non è tutto il
mondo con le loro ricette preferite e di
ognuna di loro scritto una storia e la
ricetta quindi questo per esempio
l'inter abbia questo in etiopia un
piatto piccantissimo in brasile fagioli
carne di maiale anche quando i 50 gradi
in kenya questo era un po rischio dolori
di stomaco ma fortunatamente è andata
bene questa le fiji pesce freschissimo
appena pescato eccezionale con una
tazzina di cocco buonissimo lo vorrei
ora in bolivia e ad haiti anche questo
ero lì in un periodo in cui c'era un
epidemia di colera molto alta quindi
insomma che questo annunciato molto
rischio ma per fortuna anche in questo
caso è andata bene in malawi appunto che
non hai dietro siena ma in malawi e
mangiano mi hanno preparato dal piatto
di di bacarozzi n'era veramente gustoso
però per per farli per essere educato in
qualcuno l'ho dovuto mangiare questo in
turchia
questo piccantissimo in india come più o
meno piccante il calendario che lei si
chiama il caso questo è una buonissima e
guana delle cayman cucinata però con
salsa honduregna e un po ma disgustato
perché era l'idea che mi disgusta vate
questo animale però devo dire che il
sapore non era poi così male era quasi
pollo e questa invece mia mamma che l'ha
messa che mentre viaggiavo ed è
diventata nonna grazie non a me ma la
mia sorella e quindi l'ho inserita nel
progetto last minute e con tutte queste
fotografie sono uscite venti giorni fa
sul libro pubblicato in inglese francese
cinese da un editore americano che
raccoglie 60 ricette di 60 nonne in
tutto il mondo quindi questo è quello
che ho fatto negli ultimi 45 anni
tuttora sto continuando a viaggiare a
girare il mondo sono tornato ieri da
berlino dopo un viaggio di tre mesi in
realtà che durava che è partito dai
caraibi finito in canada e poi a berlino
e riparto fra 20 giorni per l'asia
quindi sarò tre mesi tra cina corea
tailandia e giappone tuttora continua
viaggiare con il couchsurfing perché
oltre a essere un modo economico per
viaggiare a mare sicuramente
il metodo migliore per entrare veramente
in contatto con le culture locali perché
non sono in hotel da solo a guardare la
televisione ma sono con gente locale che
mi aiuta che mi che mi ospita che mi dà
consigli su cosa fare dove trovare le
cose che devo fotografare e quindi
insomma consiglio a tutti voi se volete
di provare il couchsurfing di iscrivermi